Now, to define max-min fairness, let's first assume
that we have some allocation of rates across
flows x i. Now, we say that this
allocation is max-min fair if increasing any rate
x i implies that some other x j that is smaller than x i must be
decreased. To accommodate for the increase in x
i. So in other words, the allocation is max-min
fair if we can't make, any one of these flow rates better off, without making
some flow rate worse off, that's already worse than the flow rate xi.
So the upshot results in small demands getting exactly what they asked for, and
the larger demands splitting the remaining capacity
among themselves equally. More formally, we perform this
procedure as follows. We allocate resources to users
in order of increasing demand. No user receives
more than what they requested. And users that
still have unsatisfied demands, split the remaining resources.